[Music]
a
I
[Music]
well hey surprise everybody uh you know
I don't have an intro for this like I
said I do a flickers of fear intro but I
just never put it over here and I just
don't even bother with it you know what
I mean so yeah uh as I said on the
stream last night um I am doing another
movie review today I feel like I haven't
done any movie review or book review
like live streams in the past couple
weeks I guess because you know you guys
know um you know because of Tom's dad
dying and him being in Mississippi and I
don't know and I was really busy like
with all this freelance work and I
didn't really have the time or the
wherewithal uh to do any reviews but I'm
slowly getting back into it and this is
one that I watched the other afternoon
when I had a couple spare hours and I
thought that I would talk about it and
hey Tammy how are you doing I know I'm a
little bit late starting today because
we had all these errands to run and then
I had a bunch of freelance work I had to
do and stuff like that but I really did
want to do this because I watched this
movie a long time ago and I kind of want
to talk about it before I forgot before
I forgot about it you know what I mean
uh because you know what I mean uh hey
bethina what's up um yeah it's nice to
see everybody so this movie
here I had been hearing about this it
kept turning up on a lot of Cu you know
I've said this before I periodically
check a lot of um you know lists of best
horror movies of the Year blah blah so
this one was turning up on a lot of
people's best horror of 2023 lists and I
saw it pop up on shutter it's actually a
shutter
original so I'm not really sure if you
can get it on other streaming servers I
imagine that you probably can but I
guess that just means that shudder
helped out with the money or the
distribution or whatever um so I have
shudder and it's really awesome so I was
like well I'm going to sit down and
watch it because the thing that
intrigued me about it I didn't know a
great deal about it other than that it
was set in 1945 hence the title Brooklyn
45 and I tend to kind of like period
pieces in horror depends on what uh you
know sub genre it is and stuff but I was
like so that kind of intrigued me that
it was set in
1945 and also it centers around a seance
and anybody who knows me knows I love a
good Seance in a movie um so I really
like movies about seances or movies with
seances in them uh so I thought that was
really cool particularly I was thinking
uh specifically of the Seance scene in
the changeling which I think is probably
my favorite Seance scene ever but I just
really like I like the whole like Seance
spiritualism Vibe so I like anything
that's kind of set around that aesthetic
I guess so this sounded really good so I
kind of Dove right in now I didn't know
it when I first started watching it but
the movie was directed by Ted gagan is I
think how you pronounce last name it's
not in any way shape or form spelled
like that but it's a gelic last name so
I actually did before the video I was
like wait I don't even know how the
[__] pronounce I've seen his name
everywhere but I don't even know how to
pronounce it so I looked it up and
apparently that's the gay look
pronunciation is gigant even though
there's way more letters than you would
think yeah so um so hopefully I got that
right if I didn't I'm sorry Ted but Ted
gagan also directed a bunch of other
movies that I've seen over the years um
one of them was we are still here from
2015 which was actually pretty good I
think I wrote a review of it on my blog
um a couple years back it had Barbara
krampton in it which is always cool
there's a lot of famous people in it but
I remember her being in it and uh I
remember liking it but I don't think I
liked the end I think is how that turned
out um he also directed Mohawk from 2017
which I think me and Tom reviewed if I'm
not mistaken and also he directed
satanic Panic which came out in 2019
which is like a horror comedy I'm pretty
sure
that we reviewed that one too cuz I know
I've seen it and I think we watched it
together and I'm pretty sure we did like
a matina about it or something like that
and I remember that one being pretty fun
so this is the same director as all of
those but this is a lot different it
seems like every movie that he does that
comes out that I've seen because this is
the fourth movie of his that I've seen
has been like completely different which
I guess is
good so um apparently the idea for this
movie Brooklyn 45 came about
because um his 2015 movie we are still
here also had a seance scene in it and
he said I was constantly getting like
fans of the movie like coming up and
being like that was their favorite scene
and he was just kind of like well why
don't I just make a whole movie like
based around a seance you know what I'm
saying so he thought that would be a
cool idea um and because he wanted the
movie specifically to kind of tackle
themes of paranoia and like hatred of
the other I guess like during wartime he
decided to set it just after the end of
World War II so his dad it so happened
was a quadriplegic Air Force veteran um
he later on after the war like he became
a history teacher and he actually
consulted on this script because the
script was written many years ago um to
kind of make sure that everything was
accurate um sadly his dad passed away I
believe in 2019 so he didn't ever get to
see the finished film but he did
actually consult on the script so all
the military stuff was correct you know
what I'm saying now I'm going to say
right off the bat dug this but this is
definitely one of those movies that is
not going to be for
everyone I think uh largely that's
because it's a chamber piece essentially
Hello Kenny how are you um it very much
plays out like a stage drama you could
very easily um do this on a stage you
know what I'm saying uh it's all set in
one location like pretty much just in
one room there's a couple scenes like
outside the house and stuff like that
but it's pretty much all in one room um
it takes place in real time um and it's
pretty much like most of the movie is
just long stretches of dialogue that are
kind of occasionally interspersed with
violence you know just like sudden
bursts of violence it's kind of like
that so like I said I ended up really
digging the vibe of it but I I will say
that I do think it got slightly
repetitive in the second act um it's not
long the movie is not long I think it's
only 93 minutes but I think there were a
few scenes that could have been like
shortened or trimmed a little bit just
because some of the conversations that
they had were a little bit repetitive in
the sense that they were kind of you
know talking about what are we going to
do about this like they would talk about
it like a few times you know what I mean
when really they only had to talk about
it one time that's all I'm saying so
it's not a big deal but there probably
were a couple conversations and stuff
that could have been shortened um but if
you're on the wavelength of this movie
um I think it's like a pretty decent
watch especially like I said if you kind
of like just these real small like one
location kind of
movies so at the beginning of the movie
we're kind of introduced to the ensemble
cast now they're all veterans of the war
as well as you know that you're led to
assume that they've been like friends
for a really long time you know what I
mean so they're all gathering at this
Brooklyn
Brownstone um by one of them is invited
them all there but at first they don't
know and you don't know like why been
invited there they have like suspicions
they're like oh well it's probably this
but they're not entirely sure like what
exactly the deal is you know what I mean
so the people in the movie so you have
uh Marla
Sheridan and she kind of has a
reputation for being like the best
interrogator in the country like she got
people to confess to all kind of stuff
like during the war and stuff like she's
really sh [__] hot at it um and also
maybe engages in some light torture so
there's that too um but she seems like
an okay person other wise like everybody
does it's it's kind of like a very
morally gray kind of kind of people you
know what I'm saying um now she's
married to this guy named Bob who I
don't know if I'd go so far as to call
him like a milk toast but he's kind of
like a little bit more passive he's not
like as militaristic or gung-ho he was
like a he worked at the Pentagon but he
was more like a pencil Pusher type thing
so he gets kind of like you know sort of
razed by the other people for like not
being on the front lines or like not
being in the battles you know what I
mean so he's kind of a little bit
sensitive about that but Marlo seems to
like him for that very reason because
he's not like so out there and like a
killer and everything like that but he
was in the war effort he was just like
in an office essentially and then you
have major Paul DeFranco who's this very
Charming he's kind of a I guess he's
like a semi out gay man like everybody
there like knows that he's gay but I
don't know if like The Wider world knows
or anything and they just kind of like
make jokes about it um and he's
actually set to be uh tried shortly for
war crimes um which he and he's very
much hoping to get off with that but you
know you find out stuff about that later
on and then you have major archal
Stanton who is this hard ass
[__] much like Arley hery kind
of thing not quite as over the top as
that but in a similar kind of vein you
know what I'm saying and he's just kind
of like these no mercy [__] you
know what I mean it's just like America
love it or leave it you know he was one
of those kind of dudes but he's like a
good like nuanced character but he's
very much you know if you don't like it
you can [__] off and [__] these Germans
and all this other kind of stuff so he's
the very much that kind of
dude so this whole get together is being
hosted at the home of another one of
their friends who is Lieutenant Colonel
Clive hawkster who they call Hawk he's
actually played by Larry fendon who is
was in a [__] ton of horror movies and
he directs horror movies as well um he
was in I know he was in Ted gagan's um I
know he was in we were we were still
here like from 2015 he might have been
in some of his other movies too I think
they worked together a lot so Hawk is
having a little bit of a rough time to
say the least um not too long before you
know prior to the events of the movie
Hawk's wife Susan committed suicide by
slitting her wrists
and Hawk is really devastated by her
death not least because he feels kind of
indirectly responsible for it um for
reasons I don't really want to get into
because it's kind of a spoiler but he
feels guilty I mean I guess he kind of
does have a right to but he's kind of
beating himself up about it you know
what I mean probably more than he
should so when all the people have
arrived um Hawk tells them and this is I
this was my favorite part of the movie I
think like because Larry fendon is a
great actor I really like him he's a
great director too I've really liked a
lot of his horror movies that he's
directed um but he gives just this
fantastically acted monologue um you
know about his wife's death and how he
lost all of his previous faith in
religion like completely and he started
seeking solace in spiritualism which is
a pretty common thing uh that happened
back around that well a little bit
earlier than that time period but I
guess it was happening still here at
during this time too so he says he's
actually not really even sure if ghosts
are real
either but he tells them he's like you
know the thought of my wife just being
completely gone like you know and I'll
never see her again and she's just ashes
and there's nothing left um he finds
that even more horrifying than the idea
that her ghost might still be like
hanging around and still be maybe kind
of M M at him for having a hand in her
killing herself or like you know um
being partly responsible for the reason
why she killed herself anyway so he has
like a long thing about that and at this
point um his friends are all really kind
of starting to worry because he seems
like he's um going a little bit off the
deep end you know what I mean which is
understandable um it hasn't been that
long since his wife died but he seems
like he's kind of losing it a little bit
so his friends are like very concerned
and they try to reason with him
um you know they think he's just right
on the edge and they don't know what
he's going to do but he is like pretty
adamant he's like look I need you guys
here tonight I need you to do this with
me this is really
important now he wants to prove that
Susan his wife is still out there
somewhere so how he plans to do that is
by having a seance in order to contact
her and at first you think you know
hopefully he'll be able to you know free
himself of the guilt that he feels and
like doubts about whether she's still
out there and stuff like that like he
really wants to prove that there's an
afterlife and stuff now Hawk admits he
doesn't really know what he's doing um
in regards to all the Seance business
which I guess no one really does now
that I think about it but he's read a
bunch of books on the subject and he
figures he's just going to wing it and
like see what happens right so he does
like some of the stuff that they say in
the
book now his friends are initially very
reluctant to get involved particularly
major Stanton the hard ass because he
just has I mean you know typically he
just has absolutely no time or patience
for this paranormal [__] and he
suspects that they're all enabling
Hawk's delusions which is going to be
worse for him in the long run um but
finally he's just so adamant and he's
just so pitiful that they are finally
like okay fine you know we'll do this
with you even though we're not happy
about it you know what I mean so like I
said I don't this this is a newish movie
this just came out in 2023 so I don't
really want to spoil too much about what
happens because um I think it's this
movie is better if you don't know what's
going to happen you know what I mean um
but I will say it's not too much of a
spoiler to say that despite Hawk being
clueless in how to run a seance which
you know most people would be to be fair
um the Seance works way better than
anybody anticipated way better um I mean
all kinds of ostensibly Supernatural
stuff happens like there's this
violently banging closet door like
candles light by themselves um there's a
he has like a locket that belonged to
Susan that has like a little bit it
looks like a little bit of the fabric
that she was wearing when she killed
herself like sort has blood on it and he
has it like inside the locket and the
locket starts doing some weird [__] that
normally lockets wouldn't do we'll we'll
put it that way
um now at first like most of the
participants in the Seance uh you know
particularly major Stanton like I said
who's kind of a hard ass um are very
skeptical and they think kind of the
whole thing is a setup you know what I
mean um but eventually the Paranormal
[__] that's going on it just becomes so
obviously real that everybody is just
forced to accept it like whether they
want to or not you know what I mean
because they're like there's no way that
any of it could be faked so as I
mentioned this is very new so I don't
want to reveal too much more about the
plot from here on out because yeah this
movie is like way better if you don't
know what's coming like because there's
some stuff that you probably won't
expect um but suffice it to say that
contacting Susan Spirit seemed like
maybe uh it was not such a good idea
after all um because it ends up not only
giving Hawk the justification to do
something kind of Unthinkable let's put
it that way um it also manages to
involve this German woman who's like a
neighbor of theirs named Hildegard
Bowman um who actually ends up having
some
involvement in the reason that Susan
killed herself we'll put it that way but
yeah she kind of lives down the street
but she kind of gets involved at some
point as
well and additionally um the way the
Seance is run and they kind you know it
kind of ends abruptly so they don't cuz
you know how in paranormal circles they
always say if you open the door to the
spirit world you have to close it back
again um or there's going to be trouble
um yeah they don't do that so because
the door to the spirit world is open it
also ends up having other repercussions
like it ends up implicating all the
other characters in various ways usually
like by revealing horrible secrets about
things they' done during the war you
know what I mean so this is very much a
wartime drama kind of thing so it's like
all of their kind of skeletons in the
closet like come out toward the end and
that's sort of facilitated by the
Paranormal stuff so as I said this is a
really
solid uh period piece have some really
really great acting performances
everybody in this is amazing it's really
good and The Ensemble the way they work
together is really good um the
cinematography the art direction is
really nice like the interior pretty
much like I said pretty much it's all in
one room but just the way that the um
the set is dressed and like the inside
of the house and stuff like that it's
really cool looking I really liked the
um the color palette and everything like
that it was just really awesome really
nice like shot compositions and stuff um
and the premise of it is like really
compelling I really dug that a lot um as
I said there are some scenes and
particularly conversations that I
thought were slightly repetitive
especially in the second act where
they're you know thinking about oh [__]
like the shit's hit the fan like what
are we going to do um it seemed like
that kind of went on a little bit
because they were having argument like
kind of similar or the same arguments
about what they were were going to do
like I want to do this and I want to do
this kind of and it was a little bit
repetitive but it wasn't that big a deal
um and you know the acting is so good
that I didn't really care all that much
to be honest with you and it was such
like the the way that the mystery was
unspooling like in all these people's
pasts coming out and stuff was like so
interesting that you know that I wasn't
really all that bothered um and I'm
going to say too and that's the reason
that I didn't want to spoil too much
about it was that the movie actually did
surprise me at several points it's like
I woo I didn't see that coming you know
what I mean so uh you know it so it ends
up going up in in directions you didn't
expect and that was like a big plus for
me um and keep in mind too uh I always
kind of give this as because I know that
some people that really like horror
movies um some people like horror movies
that are more psychological and some
people like horror movies that are like
super gory some people are that even
like horror movies are bothered by Gore
and I get that I I like all kind of
horror movies and Gore doesn't bother me
um some things do bother me in horror
movies like cruelty to animals and stuff
but that's about it um well cruelty to
animals and anything having to do with
like barf or poop or anything like that
like I don't want to really want to see
that but other than that Gore copious
amounts of Gore like does not bother me
at all but I know that it bothers other
people so I will say that this movie
even though it's largely I would call it
a drama largely um but it does have
Supernatural elements but there're Fair
I don't know if I'd say they're fairly
sparse but it's it's mostly a drama okay
but it does have Supernatural elements
and horror elements to it but there is
some pretty fairly gnarly Gore in here
like at a couple of points so if that's
going to bother you and it's kind of
realistic so if that and like I said
some some light torture so if that's
going to bother you then maybe give it a
pass but it's like brief but it does but
it is in there so I thought itd warn
youall also just a little side note um
if you see like on the thumbnail I
actually love love the poster art for
this movie it's great but to me like I
know what they were going for they want
it to look like a
1940s horror movie poster and they
largely whoever the graphic designer was
on that like Kudos CU they largely
succeeded in doing that like the font
and the the way that the art is done and
everything it looks like that but in in
the context of today it makes it look
like they're trying to sell it as a
horror comedy and it's really not a
horror comedy like at all like I said
there there's funny lines in it but it's
absolutely not a comedy it's like pretty
serious it's a drama so I'm I'm not
going to recommend this movie across the
board but I would recommend it to
anybody who likes like bottle movies
like you know everything is in one
location and it's a really small cast
and movies that are set up more like
stage plays cuz this is this could
absolutely easily be a stage play
without really without any changes I
think so if you kind of like that then
you would probably dig this as well I
kind of feel like people that are real
more
into kind of more traditional horror
films or stuff that's like overthe toop
scary or you know pulse pounding action
or anything like that um you're probably
just going to think it's boring you know
what I mean um but if you kind of like
more quiet character-based kind of
horror then you probably will really dig
it like I said there are some horror and
Supernatural elements in there it is a
same and the Seance does work so the
premise is that the Paranormal is real
so there's some ghostly [__] happening
and there is like some sparse like
violence and Gore in there too but it's
not like wall to--all Gore or anything
so it's more like a character piece you
know what I'm saying um so if you if
that sounds good to you then you will
probably dig it as I said it's a shutter
original so obviously it's on shutter I
don't know where else you can watch it
but I'm sure that like Amazon Prime
probably has it cuz they usually have
that stuff like that but you probably
have to pay to rent it I would imagine
um but if you have shutter you can watch
it for nothing obviously and I really
liked it like I said I'm not going to
recommend it across the board because I
know that these kind of movies are a
little bit divisive with some people
saying it's not even a horror movie or
blahy blah because I was I always read
um you know after I watch it and kind of
write down my thoughts on it I always
like read the other people's like on
shutter and they were pretty much like
some people absolutely loved it um I
didn't love it love it but I thought it
was like pretty great you know what I
mean um but some people are just like
meh you know what I mean so how you feel
about it is largely going to be like
what kind of movies you like and
everything like that um but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by on this
little movie review um hey Hugo hey
Danny uh what's going on and Tammy said
it sounds pretty interesting going to
have to check it out thanks for the
review yeah I mean I fig you might Pro
you probably like it a lot of people did
like it I'm just saying that don't go
into it thinking it's going to be like
some super scary like action-packed gory
bloody it's not like that it's more like
a drama that has Supernatural and horror
elements to it but like I said I love
Seance movies so anything that's like
based around a seance I'm going to be
all into it and I liked that it was set
in the 40s I thought the like aesthetic
of it was really cool so yeah uh thanks
for watching my little uh review today
obviously tomorrow is Friday so tomorrow
night we're going to do our Sidetrack
show um we're probably going to go out
afterwards so we're going to probably
just do like a 2hour you know pregame
kind of show uh we might hit anakins
tomorrow night we'll see how it going
and then Saturday um I got to drive we
got to drive over to Okala cuz I'm going
to my stepdad's funeral so I don't know
if I have time in there sometimes I kind
of like to do um movie reviews or book
reviews on like Sunday or Tuesday when
we don't have other streams but I'll see
if I have time to uh watch something
then maybe I'll do another one but we'll
see how it goes but yeah so thanks
everybody for dropping by and I'll see
you guys again tomorrow night bye